pour l'instant on n'a pas les meilleurs
supporters puisque Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
pour le boycott de cette Coupe du Monde
regardez pour lui cette Coupe du Monde
est une absurdité en pleine crise
climatique regardez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
alors Jean-Luc il veut toujours casser
l'ambiance sans déconner à il te casse
tout un casse l'ambiance
on est en pleine crise climatique tout
le monde a compris enfin j'espère on le
savait que c'est irréversible il y a 10
ans il a pas parfaitement raison on
savait on l'a quand même accepté ça
cette stade sur 9 sont en plein air et
climatisés mais ils sont fous
la coupe du monde de foot en Argentine
quand il y avait la dictature parce que
pendant qu'il joue au foot on torturé
nos potes et bien là je suis contre
cette Coupe du Monde et mes amis j'ai vu
que les parlementaires ont demandé le
boycott donc je suis d'accord avec eux
Jean-Luc fallait se réveiller avant mon
chéri maintenant tu vas faire qu'un truc
c'est que tu vas tu vas sanctionner les
joueurs et tu vas sanctionner l'équipe
de France tu vas sanctionner
sélectionneur tu vois sélectionner les
fans de foot mais là je vais te dire il
y a aucun boycott ce que la Coupe du
monde elle se fera avec ou sans la
France et en fait c'est tu travailles
trop tard aujourd'hui
ça c'est juste pour faire du buzz hein
pour montrer que voilà alors il y a
Vincent Lindon on s'y tiens qui se dit
qu'il voulait pas écouter l'événement
mais bon voilà lui apparemment il va
boycotter l'événement
mais on va regarder quoi il y a Vincent
tu vas arriver je vais dire [ __ ] merde
c'est le porte-parole du gouvernement
lui Vincent Lindon mais attends vas-y
c'est incroyable la même année il y a
des jeux d'hiver dans un pays où il y a
pas de neige
et après il y a des jeux d'été dans un
pays où il fait 60 degrés à l'ombre où
on va où ils ont construit 10 12 tas de
réfrigérés je pense qu'un grand
footballeur j'adorais me transformer en
un une grande star de football dans les
cinq ou dix plus grandes stars du monde
j'ai pas donné non mais c'est une
conférence de presse et dire voilà j'ai
eu X fois Ballon d'Or
je suis extrêmement demandé je gagne
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
j'ai pris la décision personnelle de ne
pas aller au Mondial sans prévenir mon
entraîneur et mon pays c'est ma décision
d'hier soir
au moment où a été prise
maintenant on est responsable de tous
les mots de la terre enfin on en peut
plus c'est des mythos faire la morale
arrêtez de donner des leçons aux gens
ils sont bien contents pour prendre
truc tu crois qu'il fera un film tu
crois que je ferais pas un film et bien
sûr il faut prendre de l'oseille au PSG
et manger des du bien sûr des blinis là
ils sont bien là mais c'est vrai pour
manger du tarama sur des beignets ils
sont bien contents voilà
tu me déblayer du tarama ouais ils sont
bien contents mais vraiment c'est un
vrai sujet ils étaient contre les gilets
jaunes à l'époque ils sont cons ils sont
cognac leur métier qui compte y a que
leur vie qui compte il y a que le cinéma
il y a que leur monde qui est formidable
on va arrêter la clim dans les cinémas
on va arrêter la clim dans les terres
ils sont dans un autre monde ça allait
le faire il y a un an il y a 2 ans tous
ces gens qui se révoltent à un mois de
la compétition je trouve ça bizarre
quand même les mecs vous attendez c'est
pour gagner du buzz c'est du buzz
positif mais mais voilà oui c'est vrai
on prend pas un gros risque c'est pas
très courageux c'est mieux de dire je
boycotter moi bien sûr je vais pas
regarder
les nouveaux donneurs de leçon c'est une
sorte de bien-pensance mais qui est
délirante franchement qui se taisent si
vous êtes des films de qualité ça se
saurait si je suis d'accord
[Applaudissements]
mal de notoriété de spectateurs c'est
pour ça que dès qu'on ouvre le micro il
taille le Qatar
et c'est du bien l'opportunisme pseudo
star c'est tout Guillaume et c'est du
buzz négatif parce que ça culpabilise
les gens moi je suis exactement qui est
chez lui qui regarde un match je te jure
pourquoi on le culpabilise en gros ils
sous-entend quoi il va engueuler un mec
parce qu'en gros ça veut dire qu'il fait
rien pour la planète je suis d'accord
avec toi pour la planète a parlé danser
d'avoue c'est à vous pour voir du lait
d'avoine cinéma
on arrête on fait plus rien alors parce
que les clips dans les salles de cinéma
aussi alors on arrête c'est vrai un
tournage de cinéma ça pollue là bien sûr
que ça pollue ça nous fait chier parce
que à chaque fois qu'il y a des
tournages de cinéma on peut pas se garer
dans la rue les gens qui vont au concert
oh c'est génial j'étais au concert mais
il y avait 10 miroirs sur toute la
tournée
voilà pour l'environnement on a arrêté
la clim merci c'est vrai c'est moi qui
ai poussé merci est-ce qu'on peut
reprendre quand même le le problème
c'est vous qui avez pris cette décision
sur sur mon bon conseil
à la base quand même si ils ont décidé
de faire donc ce cet événement au Qatar
est-ce qu'on pourrait ne pas climatiser
en fait ce stade là parce que
contrairement à une autre salle c'est un
stade ouvert donc il y a un problème on
peut pas climatiser un stade ouvert
là maintenant là mon avis c'est trop
tard
tous les pays du monde ne sont pas
d'accord pour ça on fait le truc au fait
le truc au Qatar mais on ne climatise
pas